set action he's got to kind of come here
to to tip do more yeah do more for some
reason when you back the body I think
face let's try a little more okay
rehearsing and action help us Lord if
the driver hi let's get out of here okay
R whatever his name is
driver
grow up sort of reading these stories
about you know Hitchcock call the actors
the meat or whatever and you know people
you know screaming at actors to get them
to cry or lying to them to get them to
do a thing and um what you find with
great actors and I work with some really
great actors is they are human lie
detectors and they are students of human
behavior and you cannot you cannot lie
to him he will see it absolutely
immediately so you have to be completely
honest with these people you have to
include them in your creative
process